the extreme heat can become a real
challenge for those of us with pets
and navigating when to go for a walk
outside can be kind of tricky
but one nevadan claims to have a
solution christian casadas explains
that's right well it's called run dog
and it makes walking your dog
so much easy right here in las vegas
despite the triple digit temperatures
think about it this way it's a mobile
dog gym
equipped with all the bells and whistles
that'll get your dog
moving he's ready to go come on
the owner launched the company recently
after his own personal struggles with
frankie
the four and a half year old american
bulldog was a rescue
but after he destroyed everything in
sight his new adopted family decided to
create an exercise routine on the
treadmill
this sparked the idea to go mobile with
two dog friendly treadmills
inside this air-conditioned van
each session will set you back about 45
bucks
which will keep your pup healthy without
the discomforts of tackling the desert
heat
but it not only will cure kind of
destructive behavior but it also builds
up their back legs which is one of the
things that
uh hurts dogs later in their life it
aids in
weight loss digestion issues and general
health issues it's a it's just like a
cardio workout for a human being
run dog also works with all the local
shelters in the valley and provides a
free first run to anyone who has adopted
a shelter dog
you can find out more information as
well as how to book your appointment
on our website eight newsnow dot com
christian casadas 8 news now
can you tell christian's trying to
manage his puppy he's got all these
options for our pet owners
the owner says each dog regardless of
the breed or the size
they react kind of differently to the
treadmill but then once they get the
hang of it it's a pretty smooth ride
brian frankie's like give me the toy
already